now Leah smallen has a book on time as
well I don't recall the name of it if
you remember you can just say it do you
recall
uh no I forgot about that but maybe the
problem with time I don't know because
plenty of books called the problem with
at least in my head okay so Lee smallen
has some views on time and I recall him
saying that it may be that time is the
most fundamental
now it might do firstly does that ring
true to you does that
okay great that's what Lee thinks prior
to researching about you Carlo I was
just thinking well at least Mullen and
Carla lupont gravity great let me start
to research Lou quantum gravity and I
was thinking that you pretty much agree
with Lee on everything because in my
head you both were the same as the
popularizers of loop quantum gravity
developers of it however as I read order
of time I saw there was a huge
disconnect between you and him on this
level so do you mind explaining what
Lee's views are on time if you can and
then where and why you defer
yeah so uh let me start by saying that
Lee and I have been I think we did the
best physics uh together my best physics
and his best physics probably together
um
all the not just the beginning through
quantum gravity I mean the start of
looking into gravity but also the the
calculations of the eigenvalues of the
area and the operator which are key
results in in quantum gravity and many
other things
um so uh
we we succeeded repeated in
collaborating well and uh we we we have
always remained very good friends all
through our life since since a young age
when we met
um so he's I count him as a one of my
very very best friends and uh um
however in spite of that or maybe
precisely because of that it's not true
at all that we have been agreeing on
ideas all the way through
in fact I would say even the opposite
we've been able to do physics together
precisely because we disagreed through
our disagreement interesting uh so long
discussions no no you're wrong no you're
wrong exactly
so the beauty of the our collaboration
for me has been being able to learn from
one another constantly being constantly
challenged by the other person
and uh and and through that getting to
to to to write down equations to do to
do calculation to put up theories and to
uh to get results
um
Lee also think this way and Lee has a
very nice way of putting this story
which I love uh once in an interview
um somebody asked him about the
disagreement with me and Lee thought for
a while and then said well look
if we had
had the same ideas
then one of the two of us would have
been superfluous
and I think it's a great idea right so
it's useless somebody who agrees with
you
so that's the that's the premise
um now uh one of the biggest uh
disagreements uh which has grown at
in in the last decade is precisely about
time
it's not so strong as a
one I think uh because uh there are a
lot of common
um
points that Lee and I agree uh I mean I
I've been quoted often to say time does
not exist but this is easily that's a
slogan slogans are you know you can take
it the way that they want and it's
easily misinterpreted time does not
exist does not mean that we have to
think about reality as just static
nothing happening it's the other way
around I think that
um you know a static reality is time
passes nothing happened
but time passes and nothing happened
um I think we have to think about
reality as a sequence of happenings not
a set of things before we talked about
things but if we go into relativity to
general relativity what we actually
describe in the it's always the
evolution of things so
um even an object the object we talked
about the pen what it really is in in my
eyes at the light of General activity
it's a sequence of processes is
something happening it's happening now
and then now and then now and now and it
just process and resemble one another
and this is we call the pen and sorry so
to interject when you say happenings are
they the same as space-time events or is
that or is that different yeah yeah if
you want uh
an event it's something that is a it's a
it's just limited in space and time and
and reality is a system symbol of this
okay so uh it's it's an example of
events
where event means a regional space-time
it also means a a something that is
happening in that Regional space type in
fact
I think what the reason space-time is
it's just a happening right right
whatever happens in that region that's
what religious based time is and what
happened is that there is a field there
is a gravitational field there is
electromagnetic field there are
electrons whatever happens there and if
there are no electrons and no
electromagnetic field there's still the
gravitational field and if you take away
the electromagnetic field there's
nothing happening there's no that
Regional space time is not there all
right
so this hap this happening view of the
world is something Lee is insisting a
lot and I also agree with him completely
100 percent
we should talk about that this dynamical
aspect of all the processes not the
entities in isolation so that's the part
we agreed it's a big part
so all the people who talk about the
static four-dimensional Universe Frozen
time
um a block Universe I think it's
misleading block universe is just a you
know a picture in our head of an
ensemble of of of events if I think of
the story of your life Kurt
it's not a block Universe story of
flowflies things happened okay it's an
example of happenings good so the same
for the universe
now where do Lee and I disagree
we disagree about the origin of the
distinctions in the past and the future
that's the disagreement
Lee uh holds on to the idea
that the past and the future
intrinsically and profoundly different
at the sort of fundamental level
so these happenings are happening from
the past to the Future
there's nothing
the past it exists fix it has happened
it is unchangeable the future is
generally open ah interesting okay
that's a disagreement I disagree with
that I think that uh
it seems to me that a best physics is
telling us
that this very Vivid difference between
the past and the future is not in the
grammar of Nature and the elementary
grammar of nature it only comes in
at the statistical thermodynamical level
when we have a
macroscopic description and therefore
with entropy and therefore we have
things you know ice melting down uh and
and all the reversible phenomena that
all the irreversible phenomena
macroscopic the irreversibility
uh characterizes the microscopic
variables there's no irreversibility of
the microscopic variable so the
distinction between the past and the
future in my opinion it's only for big
things an electron doesn't distinguish
the past from the future an atom does
not distinguish the past from the future
a glass of water
with ice and water does distinguish but
the distinction is in the in the picture
if the words glass water and eyes it's a
macroscopic description so that is
that's the point where we disagree so we
you know the philosophical idea that
it's a the schedule of the world is
about happening so not about things not
about static we're really on the same
ground
the orientation of this happening is
this happening oriented in time from the
past to the future is where we disagree
I think that it comes later on at the
fundamental level if you forget about
that the laws just don't distinguish
between the two
and Lee thinks that in some sense the
laws distinguish between it
so what does he say in response to your
justification for saying that it's the
blurriness that generates time or the
macroscopic states
what's his response
they say you you be you Carlo
I
uh
uh I'm not sure in fact next uh in in
next couple of weeks I want I'm going to
Toronto and and and that's one thing I
want to talk with him I want to say tell
me exactly what why do you think it's so
um I my reading but he might he might
disagree with my reading is that
um
the intuition of the difference between
past and future for him is so strong
um so he's holding on to this romantic
idea of experiential time and wanting to
I'm wanting to that's my forcing it down
okay that's my reading right that's my
reading but you know he might answer
something else
you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy